I think you've broken your brain well  it's two ways of looking at one this  sounds like astrology for men  um you the what LSD does in creating  those new Connections in the brain which  produce the um you know moments of  inspiration is uh it disorders the uh  established Pathways and while it's  thrilling and exciting and can make  people sound very interesting uh it also  gets in the way of  um  critical thinking because your  e there's there's a sort of um people  have done a lot of LSD they have this  infatuation with this way they see the  world now they think they've got this uh  um Insight that nobody else has into the  nature of reality when actually  um they're just confused by a bunch of  things being stuck together have you  done LSD uh no mercifully not you should  do it before you talk about it I uh I  don't need to kill someone no murder's  wrong no um there are things there are  things that I'm happy to trust that I  shouldn't try